it's just a total deflection this whole
thing with Russia I watched this guy
Mook and he talked about we think it was
Russia that hacked now first of all was
what was said on those that's so bad but
he said I watched it I think he was live
he said we think it was Russia that
hacked and then he said I know just and
there's a person sitting watching
television as I've been doing and then
he said could be Trump yeah yeah Trump
Trump oh yeah Trump he reminded me of
Jon Lovitz for Saturday Night Live in
the liar we're goin't to Harvard Harvard
yeah yeah this is the guy you have to
see it yeah I could be Trump yeah yeah
so it is so far-fetched it's so
ridiculous honestly I wish I had that
power I'd love to have that power but
Russia has no respect for our country
and that's why if it is Russia nobody
even knows it's probably China or it
could be somebody sitting in his bed but
it shows how weak we are
it shows how disrespected we are total
son assuming it's Russia or China or one
of the major countries and competitors
it's a total sign of disrespect for a
country Putin and the leaders throughout
the world have no respect for our
country anymore and they certainly have
no respect for our leader so I know
nothing about it's one of the most
far-fetched I've ever heard look here's
the problem here's the problem Katie
Katie here's the problem very simple he
has no respect well they probably have
him I'd like to have them released no
gives me no pause if they haven't they
have them we might as well find hey you
know what gives me more pause that a
person in our government crooked Hillary
Clinton here's what gives me what be
quiet I know you want to you know save
her that a person in our government
Katie would delete or get rid of 33,000
emails that gives me a big problem after
she gets a subpoena she gets subpoena
and she gets rid of 33,000 emails that
gives me a problem now if Russia or
China or any other country has those
emails I mean to be honest with you I'd
love to see him